gregory i expected to see you much
earlier here in the studio a difficult
tournament uh for you but you're finally
back to 50
how does that feel to win again
i mean it feels good to win the first
game in the tournament but obviously
yesterday's game was very upsetting i
had a huge advantage against alex
shabolov and just completely lost the
threat of the game and
lost the game was very upset so it feels
good to get back to winning ways how did
you come back psychologically from that
what did you do last night um
nothing special
basically
just
you know come down and uh
uh
whatever happens happens when when you
play black against a good player uh very
rarely you can just you know like play
for a win and win
right um
uh learn hard way that when i play too
aggressively with black pieces i lose
quite often so today you know i
didn't have winning expirations but
um
got equal position after the opening and
slowly slowly dmitri was making small
mistakes and
and actually i think yasser if i'm not
mistaken was calling the trend of the
game that is going towards the grand
master draw
after the opening phase but
you took the bull by the horns at some
point where did you feel like you're
gaining the initiative
um
it happened slowly i i don't think it
was uh
you know just one move but
um i think when dmitry played b3
uh i mean first of all when his knight
got on d1 this was already
um quite an accomplishment for me so
um yeah when um
all those moves were played um and he
played knight d1 that's already
a moment when i feel like i i already
have an advantage maybe not a big
advantage but this knight has hard time
to come out knight on g2 is also not
good
um and then it's already difficult to
play for white probably with a very
accurate play
uh he can get out but bishop d4 was a
huge mistake so perhaps was bishop f4
the right move instead of knight d1 just
try to harass the queen and uh but then
i could go to h5 and then the pawn only
two is hanging so you still have another
square to keep connection with the pawn
on e2 very nice right and after knight
to a2 queen takes c2 knight takes before
you also pick up the p2 right right
right so it's not like knight d1 was a
bad move and i do it's the the point is
that after he played 91 i already felt
good maybe it was a bad symptom right
right right maybe maybe he made some
mistakes earlier in the game
uh i'm sure he did but uh
um i don't know exactly
you know when and where but uh
yeah and um
yeah and and and now his pieces are so
passive that it probably already winning
position for him and you are also
putting a lot of pressure on his time it
seems at this point he only had six
minutes on the clock gave you the b3
pawn had to give you the b3 pawn to get
the queen back into the game
uh
any other critical moments and maybe we
can still keep going i'm not sure why we
went back
i was thinking i wanted to ask gregory
uh
if white could have uh taken this pawn
uh
was there a chance for
for him
or you didn't
check on before yeah
it was kind of complex so
uh if white plays queen shakes before
rook b8
doesn't work because
white plays knight d4
and queen twin takes g2 king checks g2
um rook takes b4
knight c6
bishop shakes c5 knight shakes b4 bishop
shakes before white shouldn't have any
problems so i don't think black has
problems because uh
you know i can put knight on d5 at some
point yeah it should be close to equal
yeah yeah and knight d5 f5 and uh
something like that and uh it should be
about equal uh however
uh instead of rook b8 i can play bishop
shake c5 so knight b5 uh queen shakes
before bishop takes c5
and that's tricky
so queen
uh
where does the queen go queen c4 bishop
jakes of chuck winning the queen
so that doesn't work
um
queen
uh okay let's go bishop take c5 yeah
queen a4
now i play rook a8 first
uh
forcing queen to b3
and now rook b8 and now rook b8 and now
knight d4 doesn't work because of bishop
d4 so
that's the line i calculated and it
looks like it works
that's your story and
you're sticking with it
just just wanted to make sure you had uh
calculated it to the very end gregory
you know keeping you on your toes well
done
testing the players i see right uh your
overall i mean you've had seven rounds
underneath you you feel rusty you feel
good you're happy to be playing chess
greg uh i'm kind of playing chess i'm
not happy that i'm not playing well as
especially as well as the last year so
right
right yeah defending your title you're
here to defend your title sorry
yeah but maybe it's a little bit too
late
running out of road
right i'm already thinking about next
year
[Laughter]
it's always good to see you good luck in
the remaining two rounds thank you very
much cheers
man